[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
robert durst finally takes the stand the
real estate air accused of murder
testifying in his own defense did you
kill susan burma
no
do you know who did no i do not
and a convicted cop killer begs a jury
for mercy stephen wiggins former
co-worker wants him to not receive the
death penalty he saved my life plus one
of jeffrey epstein's most prominent
alleged victims now sues prince andrew
accusing the british royal of sexual
assault and new york's governor andrew
cuomo resigned days after a scathing
report finding he sexually harassed 11
women i've never crossed the line with
anyone law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin amid a sexual harassment scandal
and threats of impeachment new york's
governor andrew cuomo has announced he's
resigning from office
the best way i can help now
is if i step aside and let government
get back to governing
and therefore that's what i'll do
because i work
for you
the governor apologized to many of the
women accusing him of sexual harassment
including a state trooper who says cuomo
inappropriately touched her in an
elevator while working on a security
detail
now i don't recall doing it
but if she said i did it
i believe her
it was a mistake
plain and simple
i have no other words to explain it
i want to personally apologize to her
and her family i have the greatest
respect
for her and for the new york state
police
terry an apology to an officer where the
allegations appear to be beyond the
statute of limitations sincere apology
or strategic legal move by governor
cuomo
you know what brian it seems to be
somewhat strategic to me you know he
used this example i think to demonstrate
the fact that he hired and promoted
women and if in fact this claim would be
blocked by the statute of limitations
then he's looking at something where he
is not going to be held liable on the
one hand he apologizes and he seems as
though he is humble on the other hand he
says he doesn't even remember it
happening so this very well could have
been a strategic example and it
definitely worked in his favor yeah it
kind of gives him an air of of humility
to some degree because he's apologizing
and he's it seems sincere but again
there's no repercussions for this it's
not like he's a apologizing to uh
executive assistant number one right who
there's potential charges
that's exactly right and we know that
there are 11 victims and he didn't
apologize to all of them for saying that
he did something that was sexual
harassment so yes i agree this is one
that might have just seemed as though he
had no exposure all right we'll see how
those criminal charges and allegations
continue as that investigation and other
counties look into the attorney
general's findings thank you terry
turning now to more top legal news a
vocal accuser of jeffrey epstein's is
filing a lawsuit against a member of the
british royal family accusing him of
rape law and crimes angenette levy is
here with the woman's claims
brian virginia dufrese has claimed for
many years that prince andrew raped her
and now she's put it all in writing in a
lawsuit
this photo of virginia dufrey with
prince andrew has floated around on the
internet for years galen maxwell the
former girlfriend of jeffrey epstein and
his accused partner in the trafficking
of girls is also in the photo in this
15-page lawsuit jufree says in addition
to being abused by epstein himself
plaintiff was also forced to have sex
with defendant prince andrew at epstein
and maxwell's direction prince andrew
denied the allegations in a bbc
interview in 2019
i have no recollection of ever meeting
this lady
none whatsoever but the photo included
in the lawsuit suggests otherwise the
suit goes on to claim that in 2015 after
jufree made her claims against the
prince public he emailed galaine maxwell
writing let me know when we can talk got
some specific questions to ask you about
virginia roberts the suit also claims
prince andrew has not cooperated with
u.s authorities investigating jeffrey
epstein and galaine maxwell's alleged
trafficking operation
involving the young women famed attorney
gloria allred represents some of the
women he has
relevant information about mr epstein
who was his friend
there's been no response to this lawsuit
from prince andrew so far he actually
stepped back from his royal duties back
in 2019 after that bbc interview aired
it was considered by most people to be
an absolute disaster for him in the way
that he spoke about jeffrey epstein and
these allegations brian
thanks angeannette joining us today is
civil rights attorney katie smith katie
filed just before the statue of
limitations and asking for an
unspecified amount so far the prince
hasn't responded to anything involving
epstein so should we expect him to
respond to this lawsuit
yes brian usually the first response is
not a lengthy one if there is personal
jurisdiction obtained over him meaning
that he's properly served with legal
process then the next step is to file an
answer and answers aren't usually very
interesting they just basically deny
every single paragraph in a complaint
where stuff's gonna get really
interesting as as the case goes on where
he will be required in order to defend
himself to produce relevant testimony
and documentation all right we'll see if
that happens and didn't virginia jafflay
uh try to reach an agreement that would
have delayed this lawsuit
yeah in the in the lawsuit her attorneys
actually write that they reached out to
prince andrew they sent an email and a
letter last month saying let's reach
some type of agreement on tolling and
that's really the passage of time in
which we would delay or not file this
lawsuit he didn't respond so they filed
that lawsuit because there was going to
be an expiration of the statute of
limitations to make these allegations in
court papers
so internet what do you think we can
expect after they filed this lawsuit
just as katie said maybe wait and see to
respond and move forward what do you
think
yeah i think we just have to wait and
see and i think we should we could
expect him to respond even though
uh he has not cooperated with u.s
authorities in the criminal
investigation against jeffrey epstein
and galaine maxwell we do know that um
the attorney for virginia dufrese has
said that they don't think he can ignore
this so they think that he will be
served with these papers in some fashion
and have to respond all right we'll see
how that progresses as it continues
thank you both still ahead on law and
crime daily hear from robert durst
himself on the witness stand accused of
murdering his best friend but first
emotional testimony from the friend of a
murderer can this testimony determine
the life or death sentence inside the
tennessee courtroom after the break
[Music]
welcome back now to tennessee where a
convicted cop killer's defense is asking
the jury to spare him from the highest
sentence the death penalty
stephen wiggins was found guilty of all
charges linked to the brutal murder of
sergeant daniel baker wiggins shot and
killed baker then set his body on fire
in his own patrol car back in may 2018.
now in the penalty phase wigan's former
co-worker took the stand to fight for
his longtime friend's life peter shaffer
even credits wiggins was saving his life
during his emotional testimony schaefer
starts to break down saying he doesn't
understand the death penalty the judge
was quick to dismiss this and instruct
to the witness that he could not
volunteer his opinion on that matter
and
you know why you're here today right i
do
and i know that i know i where if i what
wouldn't allow me to be here yeah
you know
i i dare to say if it was anybody that
wasn't as strong as him
i mean people do have that strength and
i hear you know little ladies lifting
cars off of people children and stuff
like that
that was a miracle type of thing
pretty amazing
it's just amazing to me that
to think that taking a life
for somebody to take in life is just any
makes any kind of sense i mean doesn't
forgiveness beginning like healing
i just can't understand it let me ask
you this i don't think perpetuating
poor decisions is a good thing
the defense also called a nuclear
medicine physician who gave interesting
testimony about the state of wigan's
brain
do you have any
reservations concerns
whatsoever about the accuracy
of the the pet scan that was performed
for mr wiggins no no i mean i feel very
confident in findings
and
dr bigler based on everything
you reviewed about of mr wiggins brain
does mr wiggins have a normal brain
no i think this is an abnormal brain
let's bring back civil rights attorney
katie smith and terry austin terry this
is the defense's case not the guilt
phase but the penalty phase do you find
them making any ground in getting a life
sentence though
actually i do see them making some
ground here you know obviously it has to
be unanimous to get the death penalty it
just takes that one juror and the
psychological evidence that the defense
has put on so far in this phase has been
somewhat impressive for the most part dr
small was not that impressive but i
think dr watson and dr newberg were
quite impressive they talked about the
physical emotional and the mental damage
that had occurred throughout the life of
the defendant and that he is technically
brain damaged that's what dr newberg
stated so you might get one juror who
thinks okay because of all of this we
should not put him to death now having
said that we're in the state of
tennessee and under the law there this
is a heinous crime and if anything
deserves the death penalty it would be
this case all right so katie terry's
saying maybe kind of sort of getting
there so let's say this uh you're
representing wiggins and you have the
ability to create facts with that power
uh what do you think factually could
help save his life that you could
present to a jury
i love this power by the way brian this
is great but i mean if we're given
already with the conviction i think that
the only facts if any that would
additionally help or some absolutely
uncontroverted
proof that he did not
realize that what he was doing was wrong
and that's always the cornerstone that
we come back to it's one thing when a
criminal defendant commits an act but in
order to have that intent requirement
they really have to appreciate the
gravity and the actual result of that
action so that would be one fact that
would be helpful all right katie let me
just take that power back i'm gonna use
it for my next trial thank you for that
input and uh thank you both coming up on
law and crime daily the all-important
question did robert durst murder his
best friend the answer from the
defendant himself next
[Music]
did you kill susan burma no
do you know who did
no i do not
do you realize you have an absolute
right
not to testify
i am aware of that
do you want to testify in your own
behalf
yes
and the long anticipate testimony is
finally here robert durst has taken the
stand in his own defense
durst is on trial for the murder of his
best friend susan berman in december
2000. durst spoke in court many times
about testifying but court was delayed
due to his health concerns and the
pandemic durst along with his attorney
dick de guerin were allowed to wear face
shields instead of mask durst reads
real-time transcription from the court
reporter on an ipad next to him de
guerin would hold his hand up if there
was an objection the defendant comes
from a wealthy real estate family and
says his mother's death when he was just
seven years old had a profound impact on
his life
i looked out the window and there was
mommy on the roof
now my grandfather did not say
good god there's mommy on the roof
it was just very flat
there's mommy on the roof
waving mommy
what did you see did you actually
relevant
my mother
motion to strike
we have to have it question and answer
bob
so i will stop you when you go on too
long
understand
unders
i mean i know the rules
it just depends how their handles
did you see your mother
in the driveway
yes i saw my mother around the driveway
douglas doors
says that i could not have seen
my mother on the roof
from the window in the second floor
hallway douglas stirs to his line
durst told the jury that he met susan
berman at ucla in the late 60s and they
became friends fast
i readily found out
that both her parents were dead
and that her father
had owned hotels
in las vegas
and had something to do with the mob
when you first met susan berman
did you and she hit it off
yes
bob were you and susan ever lovers no no
[Music]
how would you
characterize your friendship
that's friends
durst says the same friend who
introduced him to susan berman also
introduced him to kathy mccormick in new
york city durst and gather opened a
health food store in vermont and got
married in 1973.
we hit it off real well
we went out a couple more times in new
york
and when i went up to middlebury vermont
she came with me
tell the jury
how your relationship with kathy
progressed
well i progressed the usual way
did you fall in love
yeah we were both in love
we both liked to be each other
littleberry vermont
was very quaint
easy to live in
you had to do not much in the way of
entertainment
you had to entertain yourselves
when we come back all good things or so
they see more on the life and death
surrounding real estate air robert durst
after the break
back now to the trial of robert durst
where the defendant is taking the stand
in his own defense durst says he didn't
want to go to work for his family's real
estate organization but felt obligated
to
so i bought a suit
and periodically
i would go into the business
and see what i needed
i felt bad
about
rejecting
seymour my dad
felt that i was rejecting
this business
which he had spent his lifetime
creating for me
if i did not feel like it was for me
i felt he was doing
what he loved doing
period and did you want to do that
i felt like i should do something
so that he did not feel
like i was being spiteful
to him
testimony for the day ended on durst
talking about how his work life
interfered with his relationship with
kathy he's expected back on the stand on
thursday for more of direct
whenever i told kathy
that i was going to new york for several
days
she would
start to get sort of upset
i think she guessed
what was going to happen in the future
which was i was eventually
going to give in
and go to work in the nurse organization
my next question was going to be how
long
you and kathy had the store
in vermont
probably a year and a half
that gets us to
1971.
in 1971
we decided
we would get married
my initial reaction
i wanted to make sure kathy was aware
that i did not want to have children
durst's team has previously asked for a
mistrial claiming dursa's poor health
would prevent him from taking the stand
after the jury left prosecutor john
lewin pointed out that's clearly not the
case not only is mr durst not showing
any issues relating to
competence etc
his memory the way he responds his
expressions in every way he is not only
testifying with what appears to be
complete command he's got a
substantially better memory and recall
than
the memory actually just testified so i
just want to make sure that this is he
can't help himself is that gratuitous no
it's opportunity
[Music]
i made an extensive record that there's
no reason this witness could not testify
that every confidence that he would be
able to
katie slow and methodical seems to be
how durst is telling his side of the
story but after everything lewin threw
at him for weeks does dirt sound
credible to you now
credible not necessarily but prudent yes
i think this was a very smart move for
him to be in front of that jury for as
long as possible i've been following
durst since the jinx and he has a very
interesting command over people and
people like him all he really needs to
do is spin these interesting yarns for
one person in that jury to have pity on
him to think that he is incapable of
this and he wins the day
yep it only takes just one and it seems
that in the past he's been i don't know
someone charismatic enough to turn at
least just one juror terry based on the
defense's arguments durst has made it to
the witness stand against all odds
what's your take on the testimony so far
you know i think i agree with katie he
looks better than he's ever looked
throughout the entire trial frankly his
hair is a little longer he's sitting up
straight yes he is a little raspy but
he's getting his sentences out not sure
why he didn't wear street clothes that
probably would have made him look better
but perhaps it's more comfortable in the
clothing he's in and this time i have to
agree 100 with lewin i think that he was
fully cognizant here he had a great
memory with dates and times and places
and he's trying to have his cake and eat
it too he's trying to say that i'm too
weak we should have a mistrial but on
the other hand here i am on the stand
and he actually did a very good job all
right well i expect robert durst to be
on the stand for quite some time so
we'll continue to follow that katie
terry thank you and thank you for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you